what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so following up to decimation what
I want to do here is I want to cover
Wolverine Origins and endings because I
think this is going to give you guys a
pretty good idea of the direction that
Marvel was going in with regards to the
different characters and teams and stuff
like that so this focus is almost
entirely on will reign it involves Bucky
Barnes Captain America so on and so
forth but this is an example of where
Marvel was kind of going back to the
drawing board with characters because by
this point we're at the tail end of
Wolverine vol 3 and what the story does
is it actually sets the stage for the
start of Daniel weighs Wolverine Origins
which was really kind of cool and
involved Romulus and involved the
introduction of bacon and involved all
kinds of really cool things but what
this does is it kind of follows up to
world reign regaining its memories
because remember at the end of the House
of M Wolverine remembers everything
about his past and so this is a little
ambiguous in terms of how it starts
because it initially just kind of starts
with a conversation between Wolverine
and Emma Frost over the phone but this
was the most logical course of action
because was Wolverine regaining his
memories now we had a lot of questions
and that's one of the things that he
says here is that for him regaining his
memories he thought would be like an
answer to all of his life's problems but
all it's done is open up more questions
in terms of what's been happening so far
and so what happens is this journey has
basically taken him to Tokyo Japan and
the reason why is because he's basically
tracking down the Prime Minister of
Japan now on the surface he's not
intending to find the Prime Minister
what he's intending to do is find the
captain of the Prime Minister's personal
security detail the silver samurai now
the silver samurai is the son of shin
Jin Yashida I think it is part of Clan
Ishida it's one of these many clans that
existed in Japan for quite some time
that was involved in criminal activities
but the silver samurai served a pretty
significant history in the level of
Marvel Comics not really popular the
silver samurai was like never part of
the Avengers or anything like that
but he was part of like the Japanese
Japanese team big hero six different
things like that and by the way that was
kind of an interesting thing what Disney
did with big hero 6 was borrowed a name
from Marvel Comics
just because of the fact that I wouldn't
really go see a movie about the big
about big hero 6 and Marvel Comics but
it was kind of a cool cool situation a
big hero 6 was really like a like a
Japanese oriented team it was faced with
like like I wanted
say Sunfire silver samurai a handful of
small-time characters and it was kind of
interesting but the reason why Wolverine
is here it's a basically question silver
samurai just because of how far back his
his knowledge in Japanese history goes
the various ties and he has through his
aspect or through being the son of
cleinias Sheeta it makes a really
interesting situation because what were
a is basically trying to retrace his
steps now what he's doing is basically
tracking a guy down and who that person
is we'll find out but what we end up
doing is we basically switch over to two
dum-dum Dugan along with Captain America
Jessica drew Spider Woman and iron man
the reason why is because they're
panicking FML remember Wolverine is a
one-man army I mean if you want to wipe
out a government you send in wool rain
like we saw that was enemy of the state
right I mean when when Warren was
brainwashed by the hand and Hydra he
ended up going through and fighting off
against a multitude of super heroes now
the what-if story that I covered where
he kills the entire Marvel Universe saw
the the fruition of that where every
single time superheroes tried to stop
them he killed him and it got to the
point where he killed them all
eventually Kitty Pryde had to kill
Wolverine by phasing her hands to his
head and basically destroying his brain
she lost her hand in the process but by
the time that happened he killed Captain
America he had killed Iron Man he killed
most everybody at shield and when he
killed every single person that tried to
track him down so it was a really cool
situation and that's what Emma Frost
says Emma Frost says you know where
shield where everybody wants to know
what Wolverine was doing why he went
after a head of state you know that Lisa
was believed to be the Prime Minister of
Japan the question they have is why is
he doing this and Emma Frost says
because he's regained all of his
memories and this sends the world into
absolute panic or at least a sim shield
and absolute panic and the reason why is
because now Wolverine remembers all
those all those abuses Wolverine
remembers all the times that he's been
tortured he remembers all the times that
he's been used and his memories been
altered so he would forget I mean
shield is just kind of in a position now
where there's like oh my god because now
there's no telling what she'll do with
the memories of Wolverine while Logan
himself is kind of a mishmash the
different people in shield dum-dum Dugan
of course a one-time friend of Nicki
release fighting alongside make theory
that eventually you know took the
Infinity formula to keep them young as
part of shield they were able to
consolidate all these different pieces
of Wolverines life and kind of bring
them together to figure out what
direction his life had actually taken
but even then
a lot of things were left ambiguous and
so between this fight with Wolverine and
with silver samurai one of them
happening is the journey basically takes
him or at least it leaves them injured
to the point that he kind of makes his
way aboard a ship at least aboard a
ferry of sorts and then just kind of
passes out from the experience but what
it does is it allows Daniel way to kind
of go back a little bit focus on some of
these the memories that Wolverine is
having about a wife that appears to be
pregnant so on and so forth but it
creates kind of a funny situation
because there was a person that
apparently killed his wife and we don't
know who that person is the question
being who was that they killed his wife
eats you which is a person he's
presumably tracking down now of course
once he comes to what this does is it
leads him to Canada's Department Kate
now this is when Daniel way begins the
process of going back and retconning a
bunch of things we talked about this
before in our video on the origin of
Wolverines adamantium what we talked
about how he oh the adamantium bonding
process was done that he had his whole
memories based on that what Daniel was
going to do is he's basically going to
go through here he's going to begin
changing things up he's going to begin
altering the history a little bit and
the way that he does this is by showing
that Wolverines time at the facility was
not exactly what he expected it to be
where he believed there was you know
Caroline's dr. Cornelius all these
different people where he believed that
they may have been there where he was
lashing out and he was going through and
he was tearing things up what is coming
to realize is that his memories were not
exactly like that
that his memories were not exactly
innocent capacity where he believed but
he had escaped the containment unit
where he believed that he had gone
through killed all these different
members as part of a part of Canada's
department king and the whole Weapon X
project that instead it wasn't just him
that in all reality he had help escaping
the Weapon X facility somebody
engineered his escape somebody went
through and they basically let down the
security precautions so that Wolverine
would escape in an animalistic state
kill everybody and then get away and
that's what we'll brain himself says he
says in his mind the way that his
memories were before they were restored
during the events accounts of him that
he was able to make his escape from the
Weapon X facility because the people who
are running it just got careless that
they considered him to be an animal but
he still had thinking ability he just
waited for a moment when they were at
their weakest when they were at their
most careless and then engineered his
own escape basically got away that is
not actually what happened now in terms
of who it was an engineered his escape
we're going to get to that here in a
second but what is happening is that as
he's making his way through this webinar
Susilo t he basically contacts Captain
America and when you get the hold of
Steve Rogers
like him and like you got to come back
in they literally try to corral him back
and Wolverine says no I've got stuff to
do
but one of the people that I'm looking
for is your old friend Bucky Barnes and
so what this does is this transitions
over to Belgrade Serbia at least I think
it's how you pronounce ability I'm not
really sure but it transitions over to
Serbia where Wolverine is trying to
track down Bucky Barnes now with regards
to Bucky you got to keep in mind this is
the whole point where he's still
underground like he's still operating
hidden away from the world because
remember following the return of Bucky
Barnes and Malwa comics during Edie
Brubaker's Captain America vol 5 that
Bucky Barnes had basically had his
memories restored by by Steve Rogers and
then Bucky Barnes just kind of taken off
that was really kind of like the magnum
opus of that whole run a true Baker
the whole idea was bring Bucky Barnes
back he doesn't know who he was he's
still operating as the Winter Soldier
half Captain America used the Cosmic
Cube Bucky Barnes memories restored and
then he just kind of goes back to
recollect himself so it was very similar
to what you guys saw in Captain America
the Winter Soldier when Bucky saves
Steve Rogers and then just kind of roams
off and tries to go understand and try
to piece his life back together
that's really what was happening here
now what what will rain did when he had
left Canada when he had left Canada's
department department cake as he had
basically put the word out but he's
looking for for Bucky Barnes now here's
how things work when it comes to Marvel
Comics with regards to this whole
criminal criminal underworld there are
all kinds of contacts that are all sorts
of resources is really just like this
giant underground now a lot of it has
roots and madra pork which is basically
the city where all the criminals hang
out and even shield doesn't go there but
when someone says I'm looking for a
person word will get back to them people
will whisper you know birds will talk
and they'll say hey like somebody's
looking for you they're trying to track
you down and so by the time that
Wolverine got to Serbia where he
discovered that Bucky Barnes was hanging
out Bucky Barnes was lying in wait now
when he gets in of course he's basically
being shot at by somebody on the roof
but when he gets in he basically walks
into an old news facility into an old
you know newspaper facility and the
reason why this is so significant is
because this goes to the intelligence of
Bucky Barnes it shows us how smart he is
and that's one of the great things about
his character when Bucky Barnes was part
of the old Captain America stories back
in the 1940s and 1950s coming to the
point where Captain America was
basically killed off and Bucky Barnes
was gone when he was brought back and Ed
Brubaker basically reckoned his history
and said the Bucky Barnes wasn't just
like a 1940's you know sidekick like
yeah I love
in Captain America that he was actually
uh he was trained to be an assassin does
the reason why Bucky Barnes was paired
with Captain America is because Bucky
was willing to engage in torture he was
willing to engage in murder if it meant
that his mission would be achieved he
was willing to do the things the Captain
America wouldn't do in Captain America
tolerated that because they were in
World War two because there were some
things that were necessary in order to
in order to ensure the axis didn't
succeed and so it was really just kind
of like the lesser of two evils but once
Bucky Barnes time had basically come to
an end once the explosion that ledges we
presumed death of Captain America when
he was frozen in ice once Bucky Barnes
was taken by the Russians and
transformed into the Winter Soldier well
then at that point he just kind of
became an assassin that's all he did he
just went around killing individuals
carrying out all kinds of different
missions but what that did is it honed
his skills as an assassin it made him
more capable he had a mission and it was
complete this mission do whatever you
have to do and he would have to learn to
adapt with regards to Wolverine
Wolverine senses are some of the best
and Marvel Comics your sense of smell is
Simpson found his ability to see so on
and so forth are some of the best and
Marvel Comics Bucky Barnes leading
Wolverine into a printing facility into
a new state facility is done for the
purpose of Bucky Barnes covering himself
in ink and so basically Wolverine senses
cannot detect him he wouldn't be able to
smell him he wouldn't be able to track
him down he would just have to rely on
his sense of sight now this is genius
because it's almost like that instance
from the movie predator when Tom
Schwartz and Egger covered himself in
mud so the predator couldn't see him
because the predator wouldnt be able to
see through the mud to detect body heat
that's basically what's happening Bucky
Barnes hides himself from the senses of
will range so it's so cool because it's
basically him just drawing on all this
experience as an assess one of the
reasons why I love Bucky so much in the
end but he's able to get the upper hand
on Wolverine and the woman that was on
the roof that was shooting kind of
shoots water in from behind and
effectively kills him and so the result
is that Wolverines more or less dead or
at least it seems like he is now of
course the cool thing about this is that
version exchange between Bucky and this
woman that he hired and this woman says
you know I'm staying here until I get
paid Bucky says go to this location
get an ATM ATM card take money out of
this old slush fund from the KGB and
then get out of here like just go into
hiding never allow anyone to see you
know when the question is asked why it
is Wolverine had come after Bucky Barnes
in the first place Bucky says he came
after me because I killed his
wife and his unborn child now this is a
huge red khan in the realm of Marvel
Comics that that Bucky Barnes basically
killed the wife and and the unborn child
of will reign because what this does is
it goes to the heart of the fact that
Bucky Barnes had so many things that he
didn't read it so many things that he
wasn't aware of because remember when he
was the Winter Soldier he would go on a
mission his he would be brainwashed his
memories wouldn't really be wiped away
so much as they were replaced and then
he would go on and complete another
mission he was kept constantly in a
docile state and while he is still
recovering a lot of his own memories
this particular memory of being involved
in the the death of Wolverines wife it's
something that's come back to him and so
that's why he realizes that's why
Wolverines they're never here we
transition to a place called Jasmine
Falls and we actually jumped back to the
past to this memory of Wolverines and
what had happened is over the course of
his life following his experience as
part of a candidate's department case
following you know his whole time being
a killer kind of being this mindless
animal but he had traveled to Jazmin
Falls for the purpose of trying to
basically find solace and he comes
across a man by the name of bando Sbarro
and this is a guy who is essentially
kind of like this instructor or this man
who's a teacher themselves but Jazmin
Falls is basically where were assassins
go in order to find inner peace and
that's the whole basis behind this
that's what Saburo says that at this
location this is where men who are
previously killers go to cast off who
they were before and become better men
and that's why Wolverine is here the
Wolverines and Jazmin Falls to cast
aside that dark nature of himself and to
be a better man now the cool thing is
that master Saburo goes to him and says
this plot of land will be your home and
when Wolverine goes to lay down to
basically sleeps the world says you're
not an animal you're a man this will be
your home when you build it and that's
the cool thing about this is because was
very Doctor Strange asked in terms of
Steven strange
more or less tearing down the barriers
of his own mind it is Wolverine tearing
down the barriers of who he was to
reveal who he can truly become and it's
really cool because with each brick that
he builds with each you know piece of
wood that he constructs to make its home
he's building himself up to be a better
person along the way he falls in love
with each sue and the two of them
basically become become pregnant they
bear a child now the cool thing about
this is that this also initiates a
ceremony when each is revealed to be
with child
Wolverine basically celebrates with
master Samara master
this is a time of celebration this is
you becoming a better man because now
you have something to live for and that
was really the significance of
Wolverines wife being pregnant that's
why it was so big for him is because now
he had someone to live for now he had a
reason to be a be a role model and
that's one of the reasons why this whole
Wolverine dichotomy works so well is
because for us is people for you and me
right like if we have a goal to aspire
toward did we say you know well I'm
having a son I want to be a better man
then that's what you become that's one
of the reasons why they say motherhood
is when girls or when women stop being
girls and they become women they step
into mothers that they begin to realize
that they have a responsibility to a
life beyond their own and in turn they
step into that role and become better
people and that's what Wolverine was
doing he was trying to become a better
human being now the issue is that in the
midst of this celebration the
celebration is designed to serve a
couple purposes the first it's a
literally just via celebration as to say
yeah man like Wolverines wife is
preggers but the other half is to also
show what Wolverines become just to show
that he's left his animal instincts
behind that he's left his darker nature
behind the problem is that in the midst
of this whole dance his animal instincts
take over temporarily and in doing so
his claws come out and he accidentally
injures one of the guys that he's uh
that he's kind of dancing alongside or
fighting alongside and the result is
that he's basically failed this test of
him leaving his darkness behind now what
the console does is this coincides with
an explosion out in the mountains and
this is when Saburo reveals the identity
of a guy named Muramasa and so this ties
into that whole origin of the Muramasa
blades those are the guys who were
intrigued by that element of Wolverines
Wolverines were that you know how to
kill Wolverines those are guys who were
intrigued by that whole more Amasa blade
concept this is where we basically
learned about this you know Wolverine
Origins and endings and so what Saburo
does it he basically gives us rundown on
Muramasa y-you know where Saburo says
that he exists as a man that's designed
to basically cleanse men's souls to help
them become better people to help them
remove the stench of past deeds and lay
the foundation for them to become better
than what they been that Muramasa is the
opposite that Muramasa is basically a
bad guy Muramasa feeds on the darkness
of men's souls by putting that darkness
into weapons forged by Muramasa which in
turn those men use to carry out evil
deeds and so with Logan kind of taking
time to himself and you know in the
mountain prize and sort of realized that
he had basically failed this test in the
sense that he had lashed out
accidentally during this dance that he
wasn't quite at peace
with himself to raise his own son that
he had gone back to see Itza but when he
got back there that she was dead of
course having been killed by Bucky
Barnes and so what this does is jumped
back to the modern day and this is the
conversation that he has with Bucky
Bucky basically says look my mission at
the time was to lure you out my mission
was to kill you and they get you to
follow me and then lead you to magic for
now the reason why this was done leads
into the introduction of a character
named Romulus and that goes into the
whole you know Daniel way Wolverine
origin skank and that's him basically
retconning the entire origin of the
Weapon X project it wasn't John sublime
or anything as crazy as that but instead
it was Romulus running the whole thing
what Bucky Barnes says is where you were
supposed to follow me instead you didn't
that you traveled up the side of the
mountain and you went to go see more
Amasa and that's what happened to is
what we went to go meet Muramasa and he
told Muramasa i want a weapon
I want a blade that will kill them all
and so Muramasa says fine I will help
you I will take a fraction of your soul
I will take out the darkest elements of
it and I will put it in this weapon the
issue is you said it'll take me years to
do this it'll take me years to make it
happen what is up happening here is
Wolverines basically kicked off the side
of the mountain and no uncertain terms
and he's more or less just sort of left
out there and we're amongst those
argument is if Wolverine is able to
survive however long it is that he's out
there it is able to survive the rest of
his life then in the next few years he
will come to me and he will look for
this weapon and so what this does is it
kind of wraps back around with this
conversation between Wolverine and Bucky
Barnes and Sophie of course what Wayne
says hey look you know you and me aren't
done but the reason why he doesn't kill
him is because keep in mind all these
things that Bucky Barnes did prior to
really his returns and when Captain
America used the cosmic Elan and all
those things were done without Bucky
intending to do it he was basically
being used and what were in understands
where it is a Bucky's coming from
because there in terms of how their
minds work they're skewed memories the
fact they don't remember everything
about their lives the way they actually
work did they share that concept they
share that then entire standard now
Wolverine will come back for Bucky
Barnes eventually but in the meantime he
basically just sort of dumps a whole
bunch of information on Bucky Barnes
with regards to the past these that he'd
done now I don't really know what it is
he said as far as I know Bucky I don't
think had an origin story had I had a
solo series at the time so I don't
really know what it is it ends up
dropping here but what Wolverine does is
he basically throws on you know a fake
identity and he basically takes back off
to jasmine falls again and when he gets
there he comes back into contact with
Muramasa
and Marie Monson says I finished
crafting this sword I finished crafting
the Muramasa blades this blade will give
you the tool to kill anyone that you
come across wielded like an angry god so
again this sets the stage for Wolverine
Origins by daniel way this sets the
stage for that great big huge general
over how long it was 30 40 50 issues
long it sets the stage for that whole
great big huge story arc with the
introduction of the Muramasa blade
itself so with that being said guys if
you are new here to come in to explain
make sure you guys have a sub button to
become part of the rod fork so you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah leave a comment down below
let me know what you guys think about
this because I always thought the
Muramasa blade was really cool I mean
it's the one weapon that will shut off
the healing factor of Wolverine
temporarily I mean it's almost a one
guaranteed way to kill him so it's
always kind of been a cool thing for me
but yeah guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later please
thank you